as conservatives we know that getting an
abortion is as easy as getting a cab in
New York City yep
Roe vs. Wade has resulted in some of the
most permissive abortion laws anywhere
in the world do you want abortion on
demand abortion on demand abortion on
demand yet somehow the Liberals
complained that we've gotten in the way
of their abortion on demand and now they
won't stop talking about the state of
Mississippi while you weren't looking
the governor of Mississippi is trying to
make his state the hardest place in
America to get an abortion now we don't
have access to safe and legal abortion
services it clearly Republicans are
trying to take us back to the days when
women died from unsafe abortions in this
country time to fly south to expose
these lives so we came to the only
Planned Parenthood in Mississippi to
show you just how easy it is to get an
abortion in what's sure to be the
opposition's shortest field piece ever
all right so we'd like to abortions
please yeah
here in Mississippi the landscape that
the politicians have created have made
it so difficult that places like our
house centers can't provide a full range
of services okay I feel like that was
very loaded no yeah that's correct
so according to Planned Parenthood
Stacey Fox this clinic doesn't offer
abortions but why states are introducing
more bills to prevent access to care
right here in Mississippi the state
legislature passed a bill banning
abortion at 15 weeks
I think these laws are tactics to start
to chip away access to what the roe v
wade decision set as the legal standard
in the United States Mississippi has
made it so hard to get abortions how
come there's a clinic right next door so
we infiltrated what was obviously an
abortion provider based on the fact that
their website clearly targets people
seeking abortions we don't do abortions
and we don't refer for abortions wait
what building next door is a fake
women's health center and these centers
that exist all over the country provide
women distorted information and often in
and information like worse for the best
for your reproductive rights in
Mississippi there are more these fake
women's health centers aka crisis
pregnancy centers then there are
Starbucks but it's still so easy if
you're a woman who wanted to access
abortion care in the state of
Mississippi unfortunately you'll have to
drive to Jackson Mississippi okay
there's only one clinic left in
Mississippi you know what that means
[Music]
and who could possibly have a problem
with a road trip imagine if you were a
woman who had a job I don't joke
cancelled or needed to put the children
that you had at home in childcare you I
don't have kids and the financial
resources to drive a hundred miles we're
rich Stacey quit playing the 100 mile
trip from Hattiesburg to Jackson flew by
and just imagine some lucky ladies get
to have an even longer road trip now
that we've made it to the states only
abortion clinic we can show you how easy
it is to get abortions on demand as soon
as we get past a few brave protesters
wait we are here for the gospel of Jesus
Christ I would absolutely counsel people
that the Lord says all fornicators have
their place in the lake of fire and so
we are here crying out for people to
consider that we stand before holy and
righteous god you want to go back to
when abortion was illegal and no one had
abortions they had them but they were
people dying after making it past this
guy and is sound logic well there's no
different than at the Holocaust we could
finally go inside the help of a clinic
escort protecting women from protestors
what a breeze after that we could
finally talk to Shannon Brewer the
clinic's director about how getting an
abortion was so freakin easy it's not
it's not that easy to get an abortion um
you have to call schedule an appointment
to get your abortion on demand all you
need is an appointment then you have to
speak with the counselor about her
options in this mandatory meeting a
counselor is legally obligated to read
messaging from the state designed to
dissuade you from getting an abortion
and then you're off to get your to visit
process take there's a 24-hour waiting
period even though the law requires
women to wait 24 hours to think about
the choice they've already made it's
still pretty on demand oh hey what you
good
some water some fruit snacks oh and a
gun oh yeah
super easy to get thank god they don't
have a 24-hour waiting and since you're
far from home you'll need to take time
off work and spend money on a hotel when
parenthood wants America to start having
more abortions because that's liberation
and now it's abortion o'clock as long as
it's a Tuesday Wednesday or Thursday
because those are the only days they're
able to fly in doctors from out of state
our abortions Rock Thomas because this
is so smooth just ask this woman who
requested that we conceal her identity
she finished getting her own SuperDuper
easy a blow it wasn't easy at all oh god
damn it I already have four kids me and
my husband and I planted him any mark it
took me two weeks to get the money
together within the first six to ten
weeks it's $600 for the procedure when
you are 10 weeks or even a day over ten
weeks it's $800 and you cannot do the
peel you can only do the surgical
procedure that's kind of expensive good
thing everybody in Mississippi is rich
no majority of women here are struggling
to you know making ends meet
everything's being stripped away from
him that child cares being stripped away
mietek a he's been stripped away all of
these things are being taken away from
them the option to have an abortion is
being taken away also in talking to you
right now it sort of sounds like if we
do want to reduce abortions maybe we
should have better child welfare
services better than health care
contraception or sex education maternity
paternity leave yeah you're born it's
like don't you talk to people if we're
so stupid how come we are winning and
you have to deal with crisis pregnancy
centers close clinics protestors waiting
periods misinformation and countless
other laws getting in the way of you
helping women Wow
maybe there are a few rope
to getting an abortion but surely there
were abortions on demand somewhere
nearby Alabama's governor signed into
law tough new restrictions on abortion
clinics Louisiana has just passed some
of the strictest abortion laws in the
country Tennessee will be building a
monument to on born children on State
Capitol ground
don't even try going to Iowa the fight
continues you you a deep state operative
is sent by George Soros to take away my
Second Amendment rights and force-feed
me soy burgers No
well then prove it click and subscribe
and join the opposition now